إنه ليس مثل العشب الذي تراه على
العشب أو ملعب كرة القدم أو أي شيء آخر
حيث يكون أه أكثر هشاشة قليلاً،
هذا عشب هاردي وزرعناه، وقد اجتمعنا معًا
لحل سؤال أساسي واحد،
ما هي أسرع طريقة لسحب ثاني
أكسيد الكربون من  الغلاف الجوي
وعزله لأطول فترة ممكنة في
مواد متينة ومفيدة، ونحن نعمل مع
المزارعين لزراعة عشب طويل القامة سريع النمو
ينمو بشكل أسرع بكثير من
الأشجار حتى نتمكن من تسخير عملية التمثيل الضوئي
لالتقاط الكربون من الغلاف الجوي
بسرعة كبيرة، وهي عملية أخذ العشب
و  نبدأ بتحويله إلى مادة بناء متينة
في
معمل زراعة الأنسجة لدينا حيث قمنا بإكثار
هذا النبات بشكل دقيق حتى نتمكن من زراعته في
أسرع وقت ممكن وإعداده للذهاب
إلى الحقل أو إلى
أراضي المزارعين من هناك ينمو
نقوم بحصادها بسرعة كبيرة ونحضرها إلى مصنعنا
حيث يتعين علينا تصميم آلات تقوم
بتقطيعها حتى نحصل على سماكة رفيعة جدًا بنسبة
500٪ تقريبًا مع الحفاظ على
سلامتها الهيكلية، ثم يمكنك الحصول عليها
بشجرة ثم نقوم بوضع الراتنج عليها  نقوم
بعد ذلك بتشكيله بحيث يصبح في شكله
حيث يبدأ في التدحرج على
خط التجميع إلى ما نسميه
الضغط المستمر حيث يبدأ العشب في
الضغط ويبدأ في المعالجة، وفي
النهاية يتم لف لوحة واحدة في الدقيقة.
آلة يمكننا وضعها
في أي مستودع في أي مكان في
العالم. الفائدة البيئية الرئيسية هي
أنه يمكننا سحب الكربون بسرعة من
الغلاف الجوي باستخدام الأرض
بكفاءة عالية للقيام بذلك مما يفتح
فرصة لحل جزء حقيقي جدًا
من التحدي المناخي الآخر.
تذهب الفوائد إلى العشب المعمر
نفسه، حيث يمكن أن ينمو في بيئات تتعرض فيها
المحاصيل الأخرى
للخطر بشكل متزايد، ويمكن أن ينمو في
المياه قليلة الملوحة، ولا يمكن أن تنمو الكثير من المحاصيل في تلك
الظروف،
ويمكن لهذا المحصول أن يتكيف مع تلك
الظروف، لذلك ليس فقط هو  قادرة على
المساعدة في التخفيف من تغير المناخ ولكنها ستساعد
أيضًا حضارتنا على التكيف مع
تغير المناخ في الولايات المتحدة.
هذه الألواح الهيكلية المخصصة للجدران
والأسقف والأرضيات السفلية هي
الأكثر استخدامًا في بناء المنازل،
وهذه هي نقطة البداية التي نصنعها
الألواح التي تم تركيبها تمامًا هي
نفس اللوحة الأقوى، وهي أكثر
مقاومة للرطوبة، وهو
أمر مهم جدًا، ويقدرها عمال البناء حقًا،
وهذا المزيج
يمكّننا من البيع من خلال شركات البناء
لصالحنا بشكل فعال بنسبة 70% من
هذا الكربون  يتم الاحتفاظ بثاني أكسيد الكربون الذي قمنا بسحبه من
الحقل في تلك اللوحة
التي تخرج من الباب، وهذه هي الطريقة التي
نفكر بها في هذا المنتج السلبي للكربون الصافي، مما
يعني أنه كلما قمنا بتشغيل
عمليتنا أكثر، كلما زاد الكربون الذي نسحبه بالفعل
من الغلاف الجوي ونحبسه
بعيدًا.  أنه لا يتم إعادة إرساله